(snapping fingers)
- I mean it's so much more like
easier to say like
'Oh, it's just perspective',
but like on the daily
when things are happening,
and you're in the middle
of doing something, let's
say for your business.
- Who do you love the most in the world?
- My family.
- Good.
Who in your family?
Pick one.
- All of them.
- You're very politically correct.
Cool.
Every day make,
in the, like literally once a day
genuinely sit there for five minutes
and make pretend one
of them got shot in the face.
I'm being dead serious with you.
Every single day, I
almost,
I said this today earlier,
I probably once a week
to four times a week,
sit there truly in the shower,
on a flight, when I wake up,
some people meditate,
right?
Some people work out, right?
To deal with whatever anxieties
or thoughts they have.
I actually sit
and truly try to convince myself
that I have lost
one of the five most
important people in my life,
and that is the biggest thing I do
that leads to the
biggest happiness I have.
Like, what?
You didn't sell enough earrings today?
Like seriously though.
People lack perspective.
It's actually remarkably easy
if it becomes the way you see the world.
Like, what?
What?
Like, we have completely lost
perspective as a society.
Do you know how many people
on Earth have it way worse than you?
Billions.
(solemn music)
- I have one question
that I wanted to ask you.
And first of all, thank you,
on the same basis of him
for giving me a framework to life,
and also making me feel not crazy
with how much time I wanted to spend
on my music and whatnot.
- You know what's really crazy to me?
Just as how I heard that.
I actually think there's nothing
the four of you could
be doing that's crazy
given how old you are.
I really fucking believe that.
I actually think nothing
anybody does under 35 is crazy.
I think it's practical
to scratch every itch early on
because you don't have any rationale
or reason to create restrictions
for yourself like family
and financial debt
outside of,
that's why I hate college debt.
I think it eliminates your freedom.
- Same!
- You know, it eliminates your freedom.
If you have a child
or you buy something you limit yourself.
Or you have a partner,
like a true,
like there's three
variables that can start
pulling from a place where
you can't be 100% selfish
around your happiness graph,
which is you have to have
empathy for your partner,
you have to parent,
or you have to pay a bill.
(solemn music)
- [Jennifer] What are
some of your daily habits
that you do daily to keep
you as on point?
- I make pretend that my family dies.
- [Michelle] You make pretend
that your family dies?
- There's something I do,
maybe not every day,
but comes to my head pretty often.
If you ask me why I'm me,
it's because every day, every other day,
no shorter than minimum
once every four days
I will role play in my mind
the tragic death
of somebody in my inner family.
- [Michelle] Really?
- Really.
- [Michelle] Okay, and what do
you do with that information?
- What I do with that information is
I use it as the framework
to keep everything in perspective.
- [Michelle] Hmm, okay, that sounds good.
- It's really easy for me to be okay
with the three bad news things
that I got today about
lost revenue at Vayner
when yesterday I made pretend
that a tree landed on my dad's head
and killed him.
- [Michelle] So you keep perspective.
- I'm being serious.
I know it's ludicrous.
Back to I say different shit.
I really mean what I'm talking about.
And because I'm good with feeling feelings
with myself,
it really works 'cause
I get really sad and scared,
and really don't want that to happen.
And then I'm super thankful
that that didn't happen
and everything else is,
you know one of my best friends
lost his father last night.
- [Michelle] Oh my God.
- Real life.
And he's really, really sad.
And all the shit we've been talking about
for the last year around business
and other things,
just, miraculously didn't matter
at all for the last three months
that he's been in the hospital
every day and every second.
It just doesn't fucking matter.
So if that's what we all do,
when it happens why not live like that
when it doesn't happen?
- [Michelle] That's 100% true.
- There's no question that I am
much happier than a
majority of the universe
because of perspective,
and it is completely predicated
on the singular variable
of health of the people I love.
(solemn music)
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Man on the phone]
Good, how are you guys?
- We're doing well, what's your question?
- [Man on the phone] All right,
so I'm trying to like start a podcast
on like talking about my community
and the local businesses.
- Okay.
- [Man on the phone] Just
wondering if that's possible.
- It is.
Do you live in America?
- [Man on the phone] I live
in Spokane, Washington.
- Good.
The answer is it's possible.
- [Man on the phone] Okay.
So should I just like start with like
- Yep.
- [Man on the phone] The small or,
- Yes.
- [Man on the phone] How
should I go about it?
- Yes.
Alex, let me ask you a question.
Are you looking for affirmation?
Help me help you.
Like the answer's,
- [Man on the phone] Well, I'm just like--
- Are you asking if it's a good idea?
Like tell me what you're
doing here right now.
- [Man on the phone] Yeah
I'm just trying to figure out
if it's a good idea.
- The answer's yes.
How old are you?
- [Man on the phone] I'm 25.
- Awesome. And you're
doing this because you want
to be an entrepreneur and you've heard me
or others talk about podcasts slash local
and you're putting the pieces together
and you're like
you can see a world
where you're interviewing local
businesses or people like,
you feel good about that?
- [Man on the phone] Yeah,
I think that would be great
to get like the local businesses
that we have out there.
- Good.
And is your concern that it's too narrow
and you might not get enough ad revenue
and then at some point won't be--
- [Man on the phone] Correct, yeah.
- Yeah, so let me give you an answer.
The answer is yes.
Now that I've asked those
questions, here's why.
One; you need the experience
and thinking about it is never better
than doing it.
Doing always beats thinking.
- [Man on the phone] Yeah, totally.
- The end.
I mean our phone call
was almost, you know,
luckily I was in the mood,
but there was a part of me that was like,
half way home to just hanging up on you,
because, in a good way, just being, 'Yes.'
And that's it.
To make a point for the
audience and to you,
we're sticking out on
being a little calmer today
but like,
it's, yes, do it bro.
Just do it.
Like I don't understand,
I mean, you're in fucking Nike country
just do it.
You're in the Pacific North West.
You guys understand that fucking motto.
Just fucking make.
Like, all this overthinking,
like, I'm just to tired
of everybody overthinking.
Whether it was the best
use of your time or not,
actually doing it is better.
Like, people spend so much time debating,
that even if they would
have done the wrong thing,
they still had more time on their hand.
I like doing and finding out I'm wrong
and still saving time.
Everyone's so values their time
or they're so insecure about
people judging their decision,
that they don't fucking make.
(inspirational music)
- [Gary] I don't, I want
people to love their game
the way I love it.
Not get the accolades
or success that I have
'cause their happiness is way more fun
than the byproduct.
And I know a ton of people
who are unbelievably happy
an make $49,000 a year,
and I know an enormous amount of people
who are deeply unhappy and sick
who make $7 million a year.
And something I've been saying a lot
and I want to say more often,
there's always that joke
that people talked about
like, around always valuing money
and they talked about
'I'd rather cry in my Ferrari', right?
And that saying always
pissed me off, right?
This notion that okay, you're crying.
You're deeply unhappy,
and the Ferrari versus a Toyota
is supposed to be some
sort of variable there,
it's such insane bad talk.
Everybody should aspire to be smiling
in their Toyota.
If you find out
and understand yourself,
and you put yourself in the best position,
and you happen to have talent,
and you put in a
ridiculous amount of work,
then you might be able
to smile in your Ferrari.
And that's amazing too.
But, these are the things that
are running through my head
and I appreciate you having here tonight.
Thank you.
(audience applauding and cheering)
(inspirational music)
- Yo bro, I've been
hanging out with Alexandro,
I've been hanging out with Hugo,
I know you know what that's all about.
Keep going bro.
FortNight is long term and if not,
the skills you learn on FortNight
will be applicable to other things.
Keep going.
- Thank you very much.
- Great to see you.
- See you soon, man.
- Talk to you soon.
- Thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
- I have a question for you.
- Sure. Ask while we're taking a photo.
- Okay, so I'm in college right now,
I'm a junior.
- Yes.
- And I just opened a channel less
than a year ago.
- Yes.
- And I have more than
0.5 million followers.
- On what?
- On YouTube.
- Wow.
- Yeah and I want to drop college,
but all my family are against me
and I don't know what to do.
- Well, you only have another year, right?
- Two years.
- A year and a half?
Oh no, two years, you just started.
- Yeah.
- You should quit.
- But they're against me, like.
And they give me a hard time
and I love them, like,
I want to do something good, but--
- You have to live your life.
- Yeah.
It's true.
- You don't want to end up resenting them.
- Right, okay.
Thank you so much, nice to meet you.
- You're welcome.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Why not? Go.
- Okay, I can't find my
passion I don't know what I am,
what to do with my life.
- That makes sense, like.
- I know I want to start in high school
and go for college.
- There's two things.
The most common things when somebody
can't find their passion is
one; they're over-putting pressure
on finding their passion.
And it becomes this convoluted
fucking whole thing.
And two; they just
haven't tried enough shit.
Have you ever tried to
cook a gourmet meal?
- No.
- Like, you know, and I could probably
sit here for the rest of my life
and give you eight.
You know, it's so heady
but like,
there's tasting shit
that I call tasting shit,
which is that,
like literally saving up $180,
go in and buying fucking like,
expensive fucking food,
and try and like make it.
And all of a sudden you're like
'Oh shit, I'm a chef'.
Like, the biggest thing
is people don't do shit.
- Right.
- They don't do shit.
They stay in such a lane,
or they make it so heady, you know.
You need me, right?
- [Woman] Yes.
- We've been working on building a--
- What's up bro?
- Sports car grading AI.
- Yes.
- And now we're just
talking of Comase earlier,
- Yes.
- So we're going to send us
over some pictures of cars,
so we can then test it on them.
- Good for you guys.
- Just wanted to sort of--
- Cool, man.
Listen, keep me updated on it.
I love the drive.
- But how will we be able to reach you?
- Email, Twitter is real good.
- We tried emailing you a couple of times.
- Two times ain't fucking enough.
- Yeah it was a couple.
- Two times ain't fucking enough, boys.
And you've got a Patreon logo.
- It was great to see you.
- Unacceptable.
See you man.
All right.
Bye guys.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] I also love
gemstones crystals and whatnot.
You need, a tourmaline.
- What's a tourmaline?
- [Woman] What it does is,
it looks like a piece of coal,
but when you put it in your pocket
all the negative energy that goes to you,
the stone pushes back against them.
- But I'm doing that naturally.
(audience applauding)
- [Woman] Well, that will help Gary.
That will help!
- And!
- [Woman] That will help!
- What's it called? A tom, a what?
- [Woman] Tourmaline.
- I might be a human tourmaline.
(audience applauding and laughing)
- [Woman] You are, but
sometimes you need a break!
- Listen, I'll get one,
but I'm going to give
you a real pre-view.
- [Woman] I'll send you one.
- I will take it,
and now I'm gonna give you the pre-view.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- No no, let me give it to you.
- [Woman] Okay.
(audience laughing)
- I will 100% lose it within 48 hours.
(upbeat music)